go ahead just tell
us I killed
[Music]
her Daniel he Jun Linker thanks for
seeing me I'm investigating a a phone
call police listen he's going to kill
me how can I help they made an
allegation was an old case that you'd w
a long time ago my boyfriend he stabbed
her you are aware that he
confessed what if he's
innocent that case was investigated
fairly what is he hiding Let It Go Dan
is one of the good
[Music]
ones there are things that nobody
teaches you sometimes you have to go the
extra mile there's no shame in that we
got our man no you got a
confession we need to cover our backs
she's got it in for us
I think he wants to fight I can do that
that's the game collateral
damage do you know the difference
between Order and Chaos you going to
stop
me
yeah